you wouldn't know impeach what's going
on in Washington you can sense when
something big is happening Cavanaugh for
instance this is an example of the
entire city being in raptured by a thing
that's happening that affects us all you
can't go to a coffee shop and you can't
take the metro without seeing Cavanaugh
face without hearing about it without
having someone come up and talk to you
about it people yelling in the streets
people screaming on both sides ripping
signs that's a thing that takes over the
entire city impeachment it's like
nothing like like the government took a
xanax let's shift a little bit to this
impeachment thing if you heard about
this you know what's funny is that I
live in DC I've lived in DC for 10 years
I made my bones in Washington and I like
being close to my subject matter right
it's very important to understand how
these people tick behind the scenes so I
have a very firm pulse on DC in
Washington and how it works I pride
myself in this I set myself
you wouldn't know impeach what's going
on in Washington you can sense when
something big is happening Kavanaugh for
instance this is an example of the
entire city being in raptured by a thing
that's happening that affects us all you
can't go to a coffee shop and you can't
take the metro without seeing
Cavanaugh's face without hearing about
it without having someone come up and
talk to you about it people yelling in
the streets people screaming on both
sides
ripping signs that's the thing that
takes over the entire city impeachment
it's like nothing like like the
government took a xanax like everyone's
out cold it feels like the producers
sort of like it's a show that nobody's
going but it's like a show that they
wanted to fail that then became the
success this is gonna be a spring time
for Hillary you're trying to learn
springtime for Hitler but that's not
quite the right analogy there but but
you know I I can tell you why you're
right because when when I was on tour
with Peterson we were it was the middle
of the cabinet thing and we were doing a
Q&A in Ireland and people were asking us
about the cabin oven and I thought how
men that is isn't it I'm in Dublin and
people can ask Jordan anything they want
and they're asking him his thoughts on
the Supreme Court justice the potential
Supreme Court justice of the United
States like that has no bearing on their
lives whatsoever there's a billion other
things that this guy could talk about
that would you know directly affect but
it's like I don't think anyone over
there is talking about it because
nobody's taught my neighbor I kid you
not I was walking the dog the other day
the neighbor came up to me and he you
know he knows what I am and what I do
and he was like so how about that
impeachment thing and the way he laughed
was like I don't even know what his
political feelings are but he laughed as
if like like it's just like you would
say it to somebody it doesn't mean
anything but it's like saying what's the
weather like you know it was just like
that's it it's catastrophic if you look
at the polling if you look at Democrat
voters they don't care and much less and
if you want to put a bow on this whole
thing
what is the set what is establishment
corporate media been covering non-stop
24/7 wall-to-wall since October
impeachment they have been making the
case and doing their best many of them
propagandists for the DNC making their
best case for impeachment of President
Trump and a guy like me who has a show
where I go out into the streets and talk
with people I went out into the streets
in Florida swing state very political
state and asked people if they had been
convinced or if they even knew why the
president was being impeached and the
responses I got in two straight hours of
asking probably four or five dozen
people but was no I mean quite frankly
no they don't
they haven't been convinced they don't
really understand why it's happening and
all of the full force and weight of full
establishment media and everything
they've built in their entire kingdoms
come together to cover one thing and no
one cares and no it's not getting
through yeah and it's not making sense
but you know it does fly it like a meme
on my Instagram about how stupid
impeachment is right and General
Grievous yeah yeah is are you worried
putting aside the reasons that you enjoy
the meme or is and everything else I
mean are you worried that even if Trump
wins that the the stage has been set
here that they'll just try another
impeachment after this and they'll just
try another that sort of that the ship
has sailed
they've said this is the route we're
going
yeah they're saying you know now the new
thing is he's not gonna he won't leave
the presidency and that's another reason
we have to impeach him he won't leave
right I mean they're the ones that won't
accept the last election like there's so
many backwards you know they usually
tell you more about themselves when
they're claiming what what Trump will or
won't do yeah but are you worried about
that just for the health of the Republic
I'm worried about that actually that
let's say Trump wins again which I
suspect he will and that if that happens
that we then just get another four years
of this and will ultimately have had six
years of just endless nonsense and then
how do you ever get out of that how do
you get out of it
the ballot said I had Michael Dallas on
last week he loves it he says we should
be in that all the time because he likes
the energy but you but you as a as an
energy guy like through the internet do
you does that worry you there's no
energy there that's what's crazy about
being in Washington being on the ground
is that there there really is no energy
there something happened this last week
two big things impeachment March for
life March for Life had hundreds of
thousands of people at it that city's a
nightmare the city's catastrophic at the
marsh life whether Trump speaks or not
Trump spoke cata struck can't get
anywhere I mean it's it's easier to find
a lifeboat on a Titanic then to try to
find an open uber or to front try and
get anywhere in the messed up grid that
the March for cuz there's so many people
in the city there were multiple
impeachment protests I covered them
it was legitimately tens of people
showing up I can tell you honestly I'm
not trying to make fun of them I can
tell you honestly less than 100 people
showed up to each of these and impeach
pro-impeachment rallies it is not
something that it's not something that
there really is any energy at on that on
that level on the grassroots level and
polling shows this polling shows that
Democrat voters are like you just get it
over with just to get it over with let's
move on this isn't helpful do you think
the Democratic Party survives this thing
I actually think this might be the end
of the Democratic Party as we know it
and it's gonna split into something else
after this well I mean with your past
you would perhaps know better than me
but I so I have I have usually been
right I thought all these people I
suspect that they cannot survive this
thing this this will
unearth all of the stuff it will cause
the the more radical socialists to go
their way and the blue dogs are all gone
anyway but like whatever the decent
whatever did you're a decent liberal
this has nothing to do with you anymore
so decent liberal was such a great point
that you just brought up decent liberal
yeah Pete Buddha judge viral clip this
week about him dunking you know dunking
on this pro-life democrat yeah a lot of
Democrats Catholic right you're pro-life
if you're Catholic so does that at all
actually basically said is there room
for me yes in the party as a pro-life
democrat he said get out and he's nice
about it yeah at the Buddha judge Mike
guy he said get out our party leave this
is not the tactics of a winning movement
so take it step back and look at tactics
of people who win they can allow
diversity they can allow diversity of
thought they can be open to the world as
it is and they wish to attract more they
were to bring in more like let's let's
create and let's get unique and let's
come up with new stories right the
tactic of a loser of people who have to
censor or control speech people who are
horrified of new ideas people that are
dogmatic in their belief system
politically and who try to expel the
people who offend them and what parties
do those two worldviews represent and
then that's very easy when you
crystallize it that way what side is the
losing side but losing side right now is
woke divisa m-- activists left who have
taken over and the host which is the
democratic party to try to push that
worldview and it is really isolating and
you have a presidential candidate who
ODS on right now the betting world says
Bernie Sanders try and run an actual
communist to be in America and anything
that though it almost seems like that's
where we have to get to this thing like
to really kill this thing and I did this
post on New Year's Day that went pretty
viral about how this will be the end
year of the woke stuff
it never gets fully killed but I think
this will be the year that it
fundamentally gets crushed enough to
change or or cause the split in the DNC
but it seems to me that if you get the
Trump Sanders thing
then we can sort of put everyone can
just put all their cards out on the
table at that point right it's like it's
basically capitalism very socialism what
do you want people and the entire world
will by the way be voting for Trump
because nobody no sane person in any
other country
well it's America to become socialist no
oh yeah that's hard to explain to people
3:00 in America for summary this is why
there's an open there's open warfare
right now on Bernie open you're fair
Democrat establishment are full of
people who are investors who are very
wealthy who have made money off the
capitalist system and they do not want
to lose it all they do not want to give
it all away ok I'll be my crazy
Bloomberg theory my crazy bluebird
theory is that Bloomberg is running as
an insurance policy to ensure the Trump
wins I know that sounds nuts but the
idea being that if Bernie gets it
Bloomberg runs so that he can get maybe
5% of the decent Democrats the the
old-school liberals thus making sure
that Bernie loses because for as much as
Bloomberg hates Trump he at least likes
capitalism yes I know that sounds nuts
and he likes trade with China he likes
it he likes that Lane being out that
trade lane being open yeah and yeah
Bernie does not i'll palea if if
Bloomberg does not get the nomination
and if he does not become president he
can still there's so position open for
him that he will be beloved and
cherished throughout the land for and
that I think he's perfect for which is
playing baby Yoda in the next season of
the mandalorian he's the perfect size
he'd fit in the costume all right he's
like the Sensibility
and I think he has the sensibility to
play baby Yoda season two Mandalorian if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlists
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell